All right, I made the mistake the other
day of watching another Crusader movie.
Even though I had sworn them off ever
since Kingdom of Heaven for obvious
reasons. It was a Friday evening, kind
of lazy. I had done my duty. Figured,
ah, what the heck? Let's give this one a
shot. And I figure we need to talk about
it. Another good learning experience.
The movie in question is called The Dark
Relic, and it came out in 2010. Let me
first give you a general plot so you
understand. A few crusaders leave
Jerusalem with a relic. The relic
happens to be a part of the true cross
of Christ which was a big deal during
the crusades and throughout the medieval
era. It was believed to have existed and
the crusaders had it or portions of it
eventually gets stolen by Saladin,
disappears, enters into legend, etc. At
any rate, this group find it and now
they're going to take it back to Rome.
And however, they find they're being
constantly plagued by demonic forces,
including a real demon. As we'll see,
the leader of this group, this band of
crusaders, his name is Sir Gregory. And
he's the typical hero. He starts off
like a real crusader who was zealous,
but having killed Muslims, he's starting
to think that this was all a bad idea,
that this wasn't really a holy war on
behalf of Christendom, that he was
manipulated by the church to go on some
evil venture, etc. And if you've watched
any Crusader movies, you know that's
usually how the heroes are. Okay, so
let's deal with the first problematic
scene. Gregory and his band come across
what seemed to be Christians and Muslims
fighting. Immediately, they intervene
and help the Christians. Before long,
however, Gregory starts realizing that
the Muslims the good guy and the
Christians are the bad guys. In fact, as
we come to find out, the Muslim was
actually defending the Christian
pilgrims from Christian raiders. Gregory
seems to realize this at one point as
the Muslim the primary Muslim man falls
down and is about to get killed. So
Gregory intervenes, saves him, continues
fighting the other Christians until he
kills them all. At this point we are
privy to this.
[Music]
>> You fight like a king.
>> You deal when you speak to a night dog.
It's Robert. Crusades are over.
>> Surely you that means that we can all be
friends now.
>> My thoughts, too.
We have been hunting these bandits ever
since they vaged several mosques.
>> When they attacked these pilgrims, we
could not stand aside idly as an
injustice was committed.
>> You lie.
It's
>> true, my lord.
The Turks fought to save us.
The Turk's name is Hassan. You will be
rewarded for your
>> did not do it for a reward.
And as I see it, you saved my life
twice. The first is my reward and the
second a debt of honor that I owe you.
We will travel these lands with you
until I can repay such a debt.
>> You can't seriously want these savages
to travel with us.
>> Find brother George. Tell him to tend to
the wood.
>> What a guy this Hassan, huh? He's
supposed to be a Turk, but he definitely
looks like and as I later found out is a
Pakistani.
Now, why would they have a Pakistani
play a Turk? Oh, could it be because
there's a lot of Pakistanis in England
and there's a point being made about how
great and noble they really are. First,
notice how noble Hassan is. Not only did
he protect these Christian pilgrims from
the hands of Christians, but he insists
on paying his debt by following Sir
Gregory until he has the opportunity to
save his life. He's also very patient.
Christians call him a dog and a savage.
He doesn't retaliate. Honorable and
noble and altruistic. That's what
Muslims are. In fact, he's another
Saladin, another chivalous Muslim that
Christians can learn from. Meanwhile,
back in the real world, historically, it
was Muslim attacks on Christian pilgrims
that actually led to the first crusade,
or at least was one of the major
motivations. The other one was the
non-stop destruction of Eastern
Christendom in the Byzantine realm, uh,
including the destruction of thousands
of churches and the massacre of
thousands of Christians and their
subsequent enslavement at the hands of
Turks. Meanwhile, here's Hassan
retaliating to supposedly Christians
desecrating mosques. As already
mentioned, it was Muslims who thrived on
the destruction and despoilation of
churches and turning them into mosques.
As for Christian pilgrims, this too, as
just mentioned, was a major motivation
for the Crusades. European Christians
could not enter the Holy Land without
being assaulted, mauled, killed by
Muslim, not Christian bandits. One of
the most notorious episodes concerned a
large German pilgrimage. And according
to eyewitnesses, not only was it
attacked and many killed, but a very
beautiful nun, German nun was taken and
gang raped until she died by those
shameless men, says the writer, an
eyewitness. But no matter, according to
Hollywood, it is Muslims who are noble,
long-suffering, put up with Christian
insults, Christian mistrust, Christian
racism, and who put their necks out to
save Christians from fellow Christians.
Incidentally, for the remainder of the
movie, Hassan, who joins Gregory,
continuously insulted by Christians.
They refuse him entry. They refuse him
food. They insult him uh in very racist
tones and call him a dog, etc., etc.,
because of course that's how it is. It's
the Christians who do that, not the
Muslims. Here's some samplings.
>> What brings Knights of the Crusade to
our humble monastery?
>> We need shelf. We have wounded.
>> The Turks cannot enter.
>> They are good people. They are our
friends.
>> The Turks
will be happy to sleep under the stars.
>> We We have traveled far. Without food,
we're very hungry. If you have any to
spare, we would be most grateful
>> for you.
Not for them.
>> They are our friends.
>> You are safe.
>> I have seen the devil. The face of
death.
>> Enough. You are safe. You dirt.
>> Ironically, however, even though
according to Christian charity, everyone
can be served. And in fact, that's how
it was then and now. Christians actually
would often times even help and give
food to Muslims. It's Islamic law that
bans Muslims from ever helping or giving
food or aid or or any charity to
Christians.
Have you ever heard of zakat, one of the
five pillars? It's often presented in
very glowing terms here in the West.
It's charity, they say. And it is.
Muslims are supposed to give charity,
give alms, etc., etc. What you're seldom
told, however, is that according to
Sharia, Muslims are forbidden from
giving any of that charity, food, help
to non-Muslims because they're infidels,
kufur, subhumans who deserve nothing but
war. The only time, the only caveat, a
Muslim actually can give zakat or
charity to a non-Muslim is by way of
trying to cajul them and win them over
to Islam. Then at one point, we finally
discover what bothers the otherwise
noble and stoic Hassan. The only thing
that really troubles him in this world,
take a look at the following scene as he
draws a map on the floor and explains
something to Gregory.
All of this is the Baantine Empire
which now consumes my homeland.
So that's what's really bothering him.
Byzantium, the Eastern Christian Roman
Empire has stolen his people's lands.
Meanwhile, back in the real world, the
Turks who rode in from the steps of
central Asia westward and conquered all
of Eastern Christendom, including what's
called today Turkey, and which actually
used to be a major part of the Byzantine
Empire, Asia Minor. And the eastern
portion of course was primarily
Armenian. And both Armenians and Greeks
were mass slaughtered as I mentioned
leading up to the first crusade. That's
really what happened. Turks stole
Christian land and later on they went
into the Balkans as we know etc. But at
this point of in in time in the Crusades
uh there's no land that the Byzantines
stole from the Turks because the Turks
were the invaders who came from far away
conquering and stealing Christian lands
especially that of Byzantium.
So nice one directors complete opposite
of reality. Next, we must talk about the
most obnoxious character of the entire
film, Rebecca, a European pilgrim who
was saved by Hassan, the Muslim, and who
goes on to join them. She is the epitome
of everything they want women to be
today. She's an atheist, and she's a
feminist, and she's pretty woke in
medieval times, no less. She's
constantly talking about how I don't
need any man to help me, etc., etc. At
one point in the movie, she chastises
both the Muslims and the Christians
after she realizes that Muslims believe
in Jesus. Asa, here's a little sampling,
which also reminds the viewer of how
silly Christians and Muslims are
fighting over nothing.
>> Something puzzles me.
You're carrying a relic that you believe
to be a piece of Christ's cross,
>> and you accept that to be real as
Muslims.
>> The Quran speaks of Jesus as a prophet.
You believe in him, too. Of course.
Although there is some debate as to
whether he died on the cross.
>> I don't understand why you fight for
similar beliefs. It doesn't make any
sense.
>> We are not fighting now.
>> Maybe there was a man called Jesus. I
can believe that. But as the son of God
or even as the prophet of God, no, it's
just a story.
>> Then that is your own belief.
I wonder
who is right that
>> some debate that he died on the cross
says the Muslim woman Sappa who's the
wife of Hassan. Uh no according to
Muslims Jesus did not emphatically die
on the cross nor was he resurrected nor
is he the son of God. Those are real
substantial difficulties between
Christians and Muslims actually. Then
there was this
>> God is everywhere.
>> I don't believe in God.
>> That is blasphemy.
>> If there is a God, why did he kill my
father and have me indentured to a
spoiled lord who dragged me halfway
around the world on a pilgrimage I have
no belief in?
>> Where's the sense in that?
>> There are punishments for what you've
just said.
>> Your God punishes those who do not
believe.
Allah subhana wa ta'ala is more merciful
than that.
>> Don't get me started on you, heathen.
>> Did you catch that? Rebecca expresses
her atheism and lack of faith in God,
only for the priest to express outrage
and threaten her for her blasphemy.
Meanwhile, Hassan the Muslim is shocked
that such a god is worshiped by the
Christians who punishes those who doubt
him. Of course, it's in Islam that
blasphemy and apostasy can get you
killed. Next, they finally come to a
monastery, which is what Sir Gregory
wanted to do. He wanted to take this the
holy relic, the true cross, which seems
to have some sort of diabolical power
associated with it. He takes it to a
monastery, hoping that true Christians
could figure it out. Eventually, the
head abbott does figure out what's going
on. Apparently, the problem is that the
INRI
on the top of the crucifix, which is
Latin for Jesus of Nazareth, King of the
Jews, which Pilate had put on, that for
some reason the directors decided to
make the most diabolical aspect of the
true cross, which causes the monks,
these holy men of God, to well, see for
yourself.
>> That cannot be.
Can we bury it in the monastery
[Music]
behind you?
>> There's the one behind me on the table.
Hello.
All right.
Hey,
You will all rot in hell.
How outrageous was that? Monks who
become all of a sudden demons foaming at
the mouth, flying around, crawling on
the walls, jumping around, and trying to
eat the other Christians. The lesson?
Well, the more one is closer to God as a
Christian, isn't that what a monk is?
The more evil they're prone to be in
reality. Meanwhile, the noble Hassan,
who was kicked out for being a filthy
Muslim by the same monks, decides to
come to the rescue of the Christians. He
and his faithful companion, his wife,
Suffa, with her two swords and bow and
arrow, come and break down the door and
enter to save the Christians from the
other Christians who are now zombies.
Next comes a very important scene. The
evil demon that is somehow connected to
the true cross finally traps down the
party as they're traveling at night. The
only Christian priest in the party calls
on the Trinity to rebuke the demon. But
the Muslim Hassan also calls on his
Allah to rebuke the demon. Can you guess
what happens next? Take a look.
>> I don't see you demon. I have the power
of God on my side.
Christ is my savior and in his name I
cast you to the pit of hell where you
belong
of the dead be gone back to hell
die by my blade
in the name of the father his son and
the holy spirit I condemn
Papa, help me.
Hello.
And there you have it. The Christian
priest calling on the Holy Trinity,
holding the cross, holding the Bible,
dies a miserable death, apparently
consumed by maggots. And another
Christian man who comes fighting with
sword in hand, he gets burned. Even the
Muslim woman suffer. She fights and
shoots arrows, but to no avail. It is
only when Hassan, the noble Muslim,
pulls back his arrow and screams Allah
Akbar, that the demon finally recoils in
fear. So for all you modern people who
think that Allah Akbar is associated
with terrorism, there you go. It's
actually a wonderful call to the deity
and helps drive off demons. Finally, in
the next scene, poor Hassan pays his
debt, protecting Sir Gregory. Take a
look.
[Music]
[Applause]
Note again how altruistic Hassan has
been throughout this whole movie. He's
always being insulted by these
Christians and he's trying to defend
them from other Christians. And now he
altruistically once again dies on behalf
of this ungrateful Christian. And the
killer, well, he's another zombie
Christian with a big cross on his chest.
Lest you forget what really drives
diabolism, diabolical behavior. Finally,
the demon is slain. Not by a Christian,
of course, not even by Muslims, but by
well, let's see.
[Music]
and there you have it. It's the
modern-day anacronistic atheistic
feministic Karen who finally killed the
demon even though she would have been
the first person to die had this movie
been realistic. And finally, even that
weward knight, Sir Gregory, seems to
finally understand what it's all about.
Now that the demon is dead, he throws
off his helmet, implying apparently that
he's leaving a chasteed lifestyle, as
all nights were supposed to be, and he
kisses the girl, saying, "We did it."
And now apparently he's going to go and
live in a sort of secular lifestyle,
putting away all this religion behind
him.
[Music]
We did it.
>> So there you have it, another Crusader
movie with all the main points. The more
Christian someone is, the more evil and
hypocritical and despicable they are.
this appears. Go watch any crusader
movie or even any movie about the
medieval era and it's always the guy
holding the cross or speaking about God
or holding the Bible. Usually a cleric,
a monk or a priest who's the most
despicable and hypocritical character or
just weak and pathetic. And once again,
the Muslims are well, they're noble.
They're altruistic. They're out to help
these crazy Christians who are otherwise
killing and robbing each other all the
time. Now, you may say this is just a
harmless movie, but this sort of thing
has been going on for a long time. this
sort of brain rot in movies, in books,
in academia, in politics, all over,
everywhere, people are bombarded with
this sort of message. Evil religious
Christians, good noble Muslims. Is it
any wonder that places like Western
Europe are in the state that they're